grexit is a total mess the deal between
the British government and the European
Union was rejected by Parliament so now
there's calls for a second referendum
yes I'm an American go with it
if you thought Briggs it was fractious
how do one a second referendum is going
to be just as divisive the first issue
is how many options to put on the ballot
a binary vote is useful because there's
a clear winner but the problem with it
is it leaves some people feeling jilted
that their option wasn't on the ballot
so the solution may be a three-way vote
it's tricky but there's several ways to
do it and a two-stage vote all options
are listed that means first asking do
you want a deal or no deal and after
that asking a second question do you
want any deal at all or to remain this
allows all the views to be represented
the drawback is that it's open to being
gamed remain errs in the first round
could vote for a No Deal breaks it in
the hopes of luring people who are in
favor of brexit but on the fence into
voting to remain in the second round
another method is the alternative vote
all options are on the ballot and people
have to vote their first and second
choices if one option receives more than
50% of the vote it's over we have a
winner but if it doesn't then people's
second choices are taken into account
the benefit is that people get what they
voted for even if they've had to
compromise on their first choice but
this can produce perverse outcomes in
which the winning choice commands the
fewest first preferences finally we have
the condor say method it's named after a
French aristocrat from the 18th century
who loved thought experiments and it
consists of three two-way races a versus
B B versus C and a versus C now the
benefit is if there's a clear winner
then it did the job but the problem is
that if there isn't it could lead to a
perpetual loop in which a beats be B
beats C and C beats a the other problem
is that it's rarely used and it's French
the trouble is the same set of votes can
have three different outcomes depending
on how you count them imagine 40 percent
had voted four remain in a two stage
vote remain wins it is the most first
choices
an alternative vote No Deal would win
the government's deal was everyone's
second best choice and it was eliminated
after the first round using the Contras
a method in a head-to-head the
government's deal wins against both
remain and No Deal
regs it is tearing Britain apart a
second referendum might answer the
question about what to do but agreeing
on the form that it takes is itself
divisive